Il y a quelqu'un..?
Yannick ?
Aïe !
Pardon.
-Comment ça pardon...
Y'a qui là ?
Bah y’a moi.
-Et moi.
Et moi.
-Huuuuuuu...
Quoi ?
-J’avoue, j’ai dit deux fois “moi”.
Non mais attendez,
comment vous êtes entrés ?
C’est très simple,
je me suis téléporté.
Je suis un vampire,
donc je peux me téléporter,
je vais où je veux.
On est passés par la fenêtre.
Non.
N’importe quoi,
ça se téléporte pas un vampire...
Oui bah un loup garou non plus,
ça se téléporte pas.
Ca je sais,
c’est de la merde d’être un loup garou.
Ah parce que t’es un loup garou, toi ?
-Ouais
Enfin ça fait cinq jours,
donc pour le moment
à part me gratter l’oreille avec les pieds,
je sers pas à grand chose.
Justement en parlant d'oreille.
Bon, trève de bavardages,
laissez faire le professionnel.
Oulà non, attendez attendez !
C’est ma victime, j’étais là en premier.
Oui enfin, réfléchissez deux secondes,
je ne vais pas me nourrir d'un cadavre...
Le sang des morts n’a aucun goût
et je suis un fin gourmet.
Mais j’en ai rien à foutre de ça !
J’étais là en premier !
Et en plus, je vais pas tuer un cadavre,
c’est encore plus con.
Premièrement je ne tue pas nécessairement,
je me délecte du sang de ma victime.
Et deuxièm...
Deuxièmement, il est hors de question
que je tue ma victime avec un pieu en bois.
Le pieu en bois, ça n’a jamais marché.
C’est une légende.
Si, ça marche.
-Pdoubt !
Bon toujours est il
que c'est moi le doyen ici...
Donc j'y vais.
-Ah ouais !
T’as quel âge ?
-J'aurais 516 ans en mars.
Et la chemise elle est d’époque ?
Huuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuu….
Il a dit quoi ?
Bon j’avoue que moi
j'ai les crocs.
Nan nan, c’est pas un jeu de mot.
Donc soit vous vous décidez maintenant,
soit j’y vais,
je la bouffe et je vous préviens,
je vous laisse même pas un doigt.
Tu vas quand même
te garder un petit nonosse à ronger ?
Ok, métamorphose !
Nul.
J'suis venue pour botter des culs,
et distribuer des bonbons !
Mais j'ai plus de bonbons.
Yannick, qu'est ce que c'est ça…
Hein !
qu'est ce que c'est ça…
Tu vas au panier !
Allez au panier !
Huuuuu...